it'll be up to chris flexing tonight to
try to hold them down his pitch well for
the marriage this would be a seventh
start three and one record of three
seven eight era
and 33 in the third he has seven walks
23 strikeouts for flexon
one skip knee high easy play there for
dylan moore
and the lead off man tonight is retired
now towards center
count lewis is there calling four
quickly two away
now he's 2-2
rolled over towards the point of the
shifts right they're dylan moore
and a quick inning is exactly how it
turns out for flex near tires this side
and order well eris volley will be the
northeast ohio ford dealers indian
starting pitcher tonight making his
start number eight he is 5-0 the nice
291 earned run average has never faced
the seattle mariners before as a matter
of fact he's only faced one other team
in the west and that was texas back in
19.
here's his pitch
and it's down low for a ball
and wait a minute did he check his swing
evidently not they made the appeal to
ted barrett at third base and kellnick
is a strikeout victim and doesn't like
it heading back to the
dugout drives away center field
and jordan luplos shy of the warning
track brings it down for out number two
two fairly quick outs for savali now
facing kyle seeger
slugged out towards the gap and right
center field seeger going yards see you
later
not typical territory for number 15.
he puts the maritals in front one
nothing
into the bleachers and right center
field
he touches them all and the mariners
have a one-nothing lead here in the
bottom of the first
mariners need a jump start to their
offense
maybe that's the moment that gets them
going here we go to the top half of the
second and left fielder eddie rosario
will lead things off
left side of the infield kyle seeger
with a shift on racing toward the third
base line now he stops he's there and
makes the catch
here's the stretch and the 1-0 pitch
swinging a ground ball cute off the end
of the bat side of the mountain goes up
with the ball this crawford steps on
second himself for one the throw to
first and it's in time for the 6-3
double play that'll in the inning reyes
out at second naylor is out at first
six three twin killing to retire the
side we go to the bottom of the second
crawford walks
first allowed by
savali and it opens the second inning
here's his pitch
swung on ground ball shortstop rosario
to the back for one hernandez to first
double play
two down base is empty
trailing houston
and oakland in the standings
ground ball ends the inning middle
after two it's the one nothing
seattle mariners jordan luplow for the
the third in
tribe their center fielder leads off
right hand hitter going the other way
shoots it to right
and it's over the head of hagerty
and luklow will roll into second base
with a leadoff double
tell you what he hit that ball a lot
harder than hagerty thought he sure did
and that thing that might have had a
little slice to it so
base hitting the left field luplo had to
make sure it went through so he's unable
to score but the indians have first and
third with one out for cesar hernandez
collection could use another double play
get crawford and more double play depth
soft pop up seeger racing over foul
ground slowing up
making the catch two outs
right back to flex and he stabs it and
he gets out of a jam he strands runners
on the corners
and this crowd is ready to absolutely go
nuts for anything that kilnick does
haggerty five out of six and base
stealing one over here to kelnick line
drive to the gap right center field
getty up down there it is first home run
in his big league career by jared
kellnick and the mariners have taken a
three-nothing lead here to third
first hit first home run of the show
jared kellnick welcome to
seattle a
the gap over the 380 side by j.k
that ball just jumped off the kids bet
first hit in the big leagues is a line
shot to run homer
into the gap in right center field here
at t-mobile park and this friday night
may the 14th 2021 remember that hit
number one in the big leagues for jared
kellnick and they're going crazy in
waukesha wisconsin right now third
baseman jose ramirez leading off the top
of the fourth inning swung on line drive
and caught with a leaping ground dylan
moore
in shallow right field the mariners
second baseman had to scale some heights
to bring that thing back down oh my
goodness did he ever climb the ladder
out there dylan moore makes an
outstanding catch
and it's what a way for the indians here
in the top of the fourth inning what a
play
five more luplow digs in drive with the
base runner in scoring position nobody
out two two breaking ball yeah center
field that's gonna get a run home as
naylor scores luplow a wide turn he'll
hold with an rbi single and the indians
are on the board it's three to one there
you go took advantage he put a nice
swing got a breaking ball he's hit two
balls i mean right on the nose tonight
first one to right center field he gets
one here look at him he's gonna turn on
it
good swing and here's the kid jared
keldich
coming up for the third time tonight
gets a nice round of applause swung on
line drive base hit into the gap and
right center field hit number two for
celtic digging for second off of the
ball loop load the throw to second wide
jarrod slides in holy smokes he's got
himself a double
and he got that one right out of the
batter's box
holy smokes jared could call his
sixth grade counselor and say you know
what i'm a big league ball player i'm
here and i'm going to stay here a home
run in the third and he doubles into the
gap at right center field here in the
bottom of the fifth celtic is two for
three tonight kyle lewis the batter and
here's the pitch from savali popped up
right side long run for anyone bowers
chasing it he's under it and jake bowers
reached out made the catch as he came up
against the side wall
spilled over into the netting
and then held the ball up and made the
catch
that was extremely athletic
that was right on the edge naylor
was right there also
watching him hernandez was sitting right
there and he just reaches out and says i
got this
he's gonna bring the infield up close
here 3-1 mariners in the seventh need
this run
swung on line drive left field demo goes
back to tag he's going to score numerous
lead goes to four to one louise terence
getting the job done with his sixth run
batted in
got a high fastball and he jumped all
over it let's now lead the tribe by a
score
off four to one two ounces in a man
aboard for kalnick bites this off into
left field three hit knight jared koenig
he drives in three he wants two again
and he's got it
we can get used to this mitch hanniger
trying to bring kelnick home swung on
driven deep to center field big time
carry on the track look it up buh-bye
two-round homer mitch halliger
anager with his 11th
home run rbi's 28
29
and the mariners extending the lead
7-1
third game since being called up from
aaa here's his pitch and it's inside and
he just hit eddie rosario in the
eddie's gonna hobble on down to first
base that's a tough one when you're down
by a bunch of the ninth get pumped
man there's a good sign that he's
jogging off
as andres jimenez will
hit run
here's the o2
swung online down the right side is it
fair if it is
it's gone and it is a home run
josh naylor
down the right field line a two-run
blast
and the indians pull a little closer
it's now seattle seven and the tribe
three ramirez at first the pitch swung
on ground ball to first up of the ball
there's marmalayos he's got it takes it
to the bag and the ball game is over and
so is the five game losing streak the
mariners win it tonight a final score of
7-3 over the indians